Laura: WE JUST LEARNED NEW
DETAILS OF YESTERDAY'S RAID.
THE "NEW YORK POST" HAS ALSO
REPORTED THAT FBI AGENTS SCOURED
THE WARDROBE OF MELANIA, AND
ALSO SPENT TIME COMBING THROUGH
HIS PRIVATE OFFICE.
JOINING US NOW, MATT AND
HARMONY.
THANK YOU FOR BEING WITH US.
SO YOU THINK THAT THERE ARE A
COUPLE OF OTHER OBJECTIONABLE
THINGS THAT HAPPEN?
>> YES, FIRST OF ALL, IT'S NOT
THE LEAST DISRUPTIVE WAY,
OBVIOUSLY A SUBPOENA OR
CONTINUED NEGOTIATION.
I BELIEVE A FIVES IN THE CHAIR
AS ATTORNEY GENERAL I WOULD'VE
TRIED TO HAVE FOUND EVERY WAY TO
CONTINUE TO HAVE THEM AT THE
TABLE TO NEGOTIATE AND FIND A
WAY TO GET THERE SO WE DIDN'T
HAVE TO EXECUTE A SEARCH
WARRANT, I THINK IT'S DRACONIAN
TO HAVE A FORMER PRESIDENT OF
THE UNITED STATES TREATED LIKE
THIS.
Laura: I DON'T KNOW, WERE THEY
LOOKING IN THE POCKETS, TRYING
ON THE CLOSE?
I MEAN, THIS IS JUST OBVIOUSLY
GRASPING AT STRAWS AFTER LIZ
CHENEY GAVE EVERYBODY THERE
MARCHING ORDERS THE WEEK BEFORE
AND ALL THOSE OTHER PEOPLE DOWN
THE LINE.
>> THIS IS JUST EMBARRASSING,
AND WE ARE TAUGHT US KIDS TO
RESPECT THE POLICE AND TO
RESPECT THE OPERATION OF OUR
SYSTEM, AND THEN YOU SEE THIS
BIZARRE BEHAVIOR, AT THAT POINT
NOT ONLY IS IT THE LAST RESORT
TO HAVE A SEARCH WARRANT, IT
SHOULD BE A LAST RESORT FOR ANY
CITIZEN, PARTICULARLY ONE WHOSE
LAWYERS ARE ENGAGING WITH THE
LAW ENFORCEMENT AGENCY.
AND WHAT SHOULD HAVE BEEN DONE
HERE IS A SUBPOENA AND THEN
HAVING THE PRESIDENT HASHED OUT
WITH THE DOJ, BUT INSTEAD THEY
CHOSE THIS DISGUSTING DISPLAY
AND I THINK IT'S GOING TO HAVE A
LONG-LASTING IMPACT THE
CREDIBILITY OF THE INSTITUTION.
Laura: CAN YOU TELL US ABOUT
THIS CASE?
>> WELL, WE HAVE SEEN A LOT COME
OUT.
REPRESENTING EPSTEIN AND OTHERS
IN THE SITUATION IN FLORIDA.
SOME BELIEVE THAT HE HAD A
BRIGHT LEGAL TEAM THAT HAD
PROMOTED THEM TO AS HIGH AS THE
SUPREME COURT.
>> THE SCUTTLEBUTT AMONG THE
BIDEN ADMINISTRATION?
>> YES, THEY DON'T PUBLISH THEM
LIKE PRESIDENT TRUMP DEAD.
BUT THE PEOPLE THAT KNOW THAT HE
WAS ON A PATH, POSSIBLY, AT AN
EARLIER TIME, TO EITHER SEE AN
ARTICLE PREJUDGE OR SERVE MUCH
HIGHER LEVEL.
>> THAT IS KIND OF A GREAT THING
FOR THESE DEMOCRATS FOR ANYBODY
WHO WANTS TO GET THIS GUY.
>> IN WEST PALM BEACH, IF THEY
DECIDED THAT'S WHERE THEY ARE
GOING TO DO THE CASEWORK.
>> IT DOES.
>> EVERY CHOICE THEY MADE.
>> WE FOUND OUT TONIGHT THAT
THEY HAD MET WITH THE
INVESTIGATORS BACK IN JUNE WHEN
THEY HAD BEEN TOLD TO PUT A
BLOCK ON THEIR STORAGE ROOM, SO
THEY LOCKED OF THE BOXES, THEY
PUT A LOCK ON IT AND THEN THEY
BROKE THROUGH IT WHENEVER THEY
CAME FOR THE SEARCH WARRANT.
SO I GUESS THEY FOUND NOTHING IN
THE SAFE.
I MEAN, THIS IS LIKE THE
INSPECTOR.
>> WELL, I THINK IT'S ACTUALLY
MADE FOR TELEVISION STUFF, SO
HOW YOU HAVE THE DRAMA THAT YOU
NEED FOR THE JANUARY 6 HEARING,
WITHOUT THESE TYPES OF DRAMATIC
INCIDENTS LIKE THAT, YOU KNOW,
TO THE POINT OF THIS MAGISTRATE
OF JUDGE, INCLUDING THAT HE
RECUSED HIMSELF FROM THE TRUMP
VERSUS CLINTON LAWSUIT THIS YEAR
AND ALSO THAT HE HAS THESE VERY
NEGATIVE FACEBOOK POSTS IN 2017
THAT HAS COME OUT THIS EVENING
AS WELL, AND SO HE WAS ABLE TO
ON THIS ONE.
AND THERE IS A LOT ABOUT THIS
PARTICULAR JUDGE BEING ON THE
CASE.
>> MAKING A BIG POINT OF SAYING
THAT FOLKS NEED TO AVOID THE
APPEARANCE OF BIAS OR LACK OF
OBJECTIVITY.
>> NOT WORKING OUT AT ALL,
MEMBERS OF CONGRESS COMPLAINING
ABOUT THE POLITICAL BIAS OF THE
FBI.
>> WELL, WE NEED TO HEAR FROM
MORE WHISTLEBLOWERS, WE NEED
PATRIOTS WHO ARE INSIDE THESE
AGENCIES TO EXPLAIN TO THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE HOW THE WILL OF
THE PRESIDENT IN SOME CASES AND
ALSO HOW THE LACK OF OBJECTIVITY
IS PAR FOR THE COURSE.
>> AND HOW THE LAW IS SUPPOSED
TO BE ENFORCED AS WELL